[Musique]
je n'arrive pas à croire que d'ici une
demi heure je ferai partie de
l'incroyable ligne et/ou dynastie le
domaine royaumont préfet royan la fois
non c'est vrai je t'assure ne prend pas
pour toi
ils veulent juste avoir cité qu'une
traînée intéressée par l'argent dans le
genre de ma chère femme
une dernière chose ensuite tu fera
officiellement partie de la famille
[Musique]
à minuit tu vas devoir jouer un jeu
c'est notre façon à nous d'accueillir
les nouveaux membres de la famille ce
sont les règles du jeu je n'ai aucune
chance de gagner ça restait bien caché
jusqu'à l'aube
bonne chance
[Musique]
je croyais que tu risquais rien
il faut que tu me crois
ils sont sûr de devoir te tuer avant le
lever du soleil
je sais que tu es là
[Musique]
si on ne trouve pas et qu'on accomplit
pas le rituel on est tous morts
je les trouvais
c'est vrai ce qu'on dit
les riches sont vraiment différents
[Musique]